hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about something called SIBO small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth okay now
some of the symptoms are bloating
because there's gas involved methane gas
hydrogen gas hydrogen sulfide gas coming
from an excess fermentation which is the
microbes are eating too much food and
fiber so you're gonna have this gas
which is going to cause pain so you have
a lot of bloating okay
constipation sometimes diarrhea
sometimes now here's what's causing this
problem okay
normally this stomach is supposed to be
very acid between one and three and
there should be no microbes growing
there okay hardly it wellmy it there
might be a couple microbes but it's not
going to be that many same thing with
the small intestine this is not a place
where you're supposed to have a lot of
microbial growth going on right here
most of the microbial growth should be
in the large intestine so we have the
stomach the small intestine which is
like 23 feet and then we have the large
intestine which is five feet okay this
is where all the microbes are right here
so SIBO is where the microbes are
growing in the small intestine and
sometimes even up into the stomach okay
now if the stomach is very very acid
that will kill off the microbes so the
deeper root cause to this problem most
the time it's a low hydrochloric acid
okay and that could come from
antibiotics anti-acid junk food
consuming too much alkaline water baking
soda which is alkaline all these things
can neutralize the acid right here and
then what happens when the normal
function of the answer is supposed to
kill a microbe in a food that you eat it
doesn't get killed it passes on through
here and starts growing right here
a lot of the food that you consume like
vegetables and and even some meat has
some microbes in them that are supposed
to be killed at the stomach level okay
so if that doesn't happen it can
actually start growing right here
there's a quite a few other causes to
this like one
be frequent eating now if you eat too
much what will happen is you won't give
the body a chance to rest or clean out
the colon in between meals because
you're eating like these snacks
constantly and that could cause it right
there because especially if there's
constipation and then the food just sits
there and the microbes start growing the
problem with having too many bacteria in
the wrong place is the bacteria are
going to compete with the food that you
eat now normally the strong acid should
stimulate protein enzymes to break down
the protein at the stomach level it
dumps in the small intestine and the
pancreas releases its enzymes start
breaking things down and the gall
bladder starts releasing bile to break
down fats and it all works together and
then you absorb the nutrients through
the lining of the colon but the microbes
are basically going to start eating that
those nutrients and then kind of keep
you high and dry and you're going to be
have malnutrition so that is a big
problem you know you can have all sorts
of additional symptoms from that alone
especially the fat type of vitamins not
having enough vitamin A for the eyes d
you know kay there can be just so many
different symptoms so but just to keep
it simple that's kind of the mechanism
that's going on so here's what not to do
what we don't want to do is dump more
fiber to feed the microbes microbes live
on fibre and they also live on sugar so
obviously we don't want to do any sugar
so we don't want to do a high-fiber diet
okay we want to do kind of a lower fiber
diet that means even vegetables you
don't want to consume as many just a
very small amount because we don't want
to keep feeding the situation and we
don't want to add probiotics or microbes
because we already have too much okay so
these two things are not good here's
what you should do in a minute fasting
okay of course I'm assuming you know
about healthy ketosis okay so that's a
given because we don't want to add the
sugar but in a minute fasting is very
important that way it'll give your
system a chance to clean up all that
residue
in the and the food particles through
here in between the meals and that's
what the body does it it helps to clean
out this stuff right here so this is
essential right here there were two
acidify your stomach with what apple
cider vinegar you can get them in
tablets and betaine how to chloride both
of those in larger amounts you can get
them together in a pill and I'll put
some a link down below for more
information but I would do probably
eight or nine of those with a meal it
seems like a lot but it's actually not
that much that'll start making this acid
and then I'll start to help you greatly
keep a very low stress life because
stress shuts this whole thing down and
it makes things worse now if you think
about what system controls digestion
it's the parasympathetic that's called
rest and digest and it gets inhibited by
the sympathetic or the flight or fight
mechanism so we want to keep a low
stress life some people just from that
alone could actually help correct the
situation number four you want to
consume in a tablet form clove garlic
and oregano this is really good to help
balance out the good and bad bacteria
okay so if you expect that you have this
you can go to your doctor and have them
do a test to actually see if you have
this and it's a they can do certain
types of tests where they measure your
gas from your breath and pick it up
exactly what it is
alright thanks for watching